this is the book you put out yes I wrote
it during the pandemic it's called what
will I do with my love today I adopted
my dog rescued my dog and I am also a
rescue I am adopted myself so I wrote it
about thunder pup my dog and me and I
told Lisa because she called and said
can you sing this year and do you have a
song and I said well I do have a song I
wrote a song about my book that's my
book I put it to music so I'm singing
that tonight as well as two other songs
for her because this there's nobody
nothing I like better than animals not
even people I feel like this is the
convergence of all your interests in one
night you get to sing you get to help
dogs and you get to be around a lot of
Bravo energy I'm in such hog heaven
right now no pen but I can't wait to get
in there because I know there's rescue
dogs and I just need everyone to pray
for me that I don't take one home I have
thunder pup and she's she's the only
child so please just I don't I can't
Kristen that argument makes it seem like
thunderpump needs a sibling I well if I
could travel with two I just know I'm
gonna fall in love I'm very nervous
about it all right we'll pray for you
inside thank you I know you've been
paying attention to all things scandaval
there's some cast members in there
tonight
house here Lala's in there Schwartz is
in there James and Ally
what's your number one question you're
gonna get answered tonight who are you
going to ask and what you're going to
get out of them
well what I want to ask I probably won't
I want to ask swords how long he knew
and I want to ask Lala who does her
makeup well I think you can ask that one
I think they're safe there I think I
might do that you're headed back to
Broadway soon how do you take the Queen
of Versailles and put that on the stage
it's very tricky but it reunites myself
with Steven Schwartz the composer and
Lyricist of Wicked and our our wonderful
book writer as well Lindsey ferentino
who's a Broadway royalty and Michael
Arden who just directed parade to grade
Acclaim and we've been working very very
diligently on making the story true
without making fun of but being able to
laugh at some of the things that happens
and take it a step further than the the
documentary film did so we finish we
pick up where they left off
so we get to tell more of the story and
laugh with them not at them
and ends up something different yeah
she's lived a lot of life
um you mentioned Wicked what did you
make of everyone thinking Ariana was lip
syncing to your voice on set I
cracked up because I have heard it and I
knew it was her and I was like why did
they think that's me we are very similar
and we have been her whole life I mean
when we talk on the phone we sound like
dolphins I'm like what are you doing
what are you doing
no no I mean it sounds so much alike so
it wasn't surprising to me
um I know that she has been diligently
working on that vocal and she can sing
anything and I'm so proud of her I'm so
proud of her are we any closer to
getting you on a flight to London and on
that set
I don't know I do love to visit there we
go I'll leave it there get you inside
sing your song thanks Kristen